our next question is from Don in Aurora
Illinois now that all of my friends and
family know that I've been declaring and
minimizing I found a lot of things that
I do want to give away to friends
because I don't want to give it away
just to donate or just to a stranger I
find things that are meaningful to me
and I'd rather give it to somebody that
is a friend that comes to mind however
I'm worried that if I give it to them
they're going to be offended that I'm
just offloading my junk on to them do
you remember the time I tried to give
you all of those neckties and I was I
was simplifying my life I this is a 2009
yeah and and I had just discovered
minimalism and I realized how many damn
neckties I I had I had at least two
maybe three necktie holders worth of
neckties I knew I had too many because
sometimes I would put more than one tie
on the the same sort of peg on the
necktie holder I had I've tried I
probably gave you 70 ties yeah and
they're really nice the evidence of tie
I kept like four of them and then I just
donated the rest but yeah thousands of
dollars on neckties yeah what did I
spend thousands of dollars on things I
am embarrassed to admit that I spent
thousands of dollars man you know it's
funny like I I've never had anyone be
offended though by me offering them them
something I mean I could see what the
trepidation comes in it sounds to me
like you know in Donn I'm not you know
trying to say your friends are bad or
anything but it sounds to me like you
got friends who were trying to call you
out on you're afraid that they're gonna
call you out on something
petty yeah and and it sounds like maybe
this is what her friends do and she's
and she's like oh this is what they
always do so if I go to them and offer
them stuff they're gonna continue to be
petty or they're gonna continue to do
this
well maybe it's I mean there's sort of
two ways to do there's a real petty
passive-aggressive nasty way and there's
a way where you and I like we can rib
each other in a way because we know each
other so well yeah but even then I can't
imagine that you would be like
good job minimalist passenger taught you
you would do it in a way that was
actually funny that wouldn't make me
feel concerned in fact if you didn't
want them you I'm sure it would
hilarity would ensue as soon as I I
tried to pass these off to you you would
do it in a way that was kind and loving
even if it was like ribbing me a little
bit yeah all done all you have to do is
just preface with your friends hey you
know that I've been simplifying my life
you know that I've been getting rid of
stuff and I've got a lot of nice stuff
and I hate to just give it to Goodwill
do you need any stuff in fact here are
the specific things I have that I think
you might be in need of I'm not gonna be
offended if you don't take them I'm not
going to be mad if you tell me no but I
just wanted to offer you know my nicest
things that I'm getting rid of to my
closest friends and family and Dawn if
they judge you for that then get new
friends you know our friend Colin right
he's on tour right now we often call him
the third minimalist because he's the
guy who exposed us to this idea of
minimalism early on he's the first first
guy who first person out of the mini
mini minimalist that we've been inspired
by but he was sort of the first one and
even though we didn't want to live his
life we were really inspired by the fact
that he was able to uproot his life let
go of the superfluous and one way that
he donated a lot of this stuff to his
friends actually he was living here in
Los Angeles mhm and he and his
girlfriend had a breakup party which in
and of itself is that was actually the
inspiration for the packing party yeah
yeah yeah he wrote about that let's put
a link to that sa podcast on in the show
notes yeah definitely a party it's a
great essay and he goes in-depth in his
book called my exile lifestyle he's
naked on the cover of that book with a
computer over his private parts as soon
as I feel comfortable taking a naked
picture I'm totally gonna recreate that
book cover I think because we're so
uncomfortable taking it would be better
for us to do it if you both put on 30
pounds for cover yeah no I know you're
going with this man the the the garage
sale room yeah actually yeah the free
yard sale room that's him dude that's a
great idea and so so as they were
getting ready to move him and his his
partner who they were splitting up they
they agreed together like at midnight
we're going to we're going to change our
facebook status so that's that means
it's official we're no longer in a
relationship at least I was official I
guess the 2008 or 2009 whenever that was
and and but in that process the 30 days
leading up to it they had a free yard
sale room that they took the the room
that want one of the rooms in their
house and said hey that's our yard sale
room we don't want anything in there if
you would find value and anything in
that room then go get it don't show it
to me just take it out of the house if
you're not gonna find value in it that's
okay too
we're gonna donate the rest as soon as
we're done with that and so that gives
that gives your friends the option
because it is better to give someone the
option than it is to thrust upon them 70
neckties of course but even then like
it's not that big of a deal right right
although I mean I guess the the what I'm
saying here is what I probably should
have done is hey Ryan I have 70 neckties
yeah I'm no longer gonna use would you
like any of these yeah you gave me the
option I remember you were like no just
whatever you keep what you want and then
just donate the rest I was like oh okay
I can do that
which we thought was the cost of taking
the ties they were nice ties I really
love the size dude I had I can't tell
you how many people in our old job and
our old corporation we worked for they
would tell me dude every time I see you
it looks like you're running for
president I'm assuming that's their way
of telling me that I dressed like almost
like too nice but but those ties were a
big part of it I was happy to donate the
rest of them I think it's important to
also keep in mind that just because you
have gotten value from something doesn't
mean someone else will too and that's
one of the things we confuse but I think
the opposite is also true just because
you're no longer getting value from
something doesn't mean it's a piece of
trash someone else might get value from
it it's not going to magically start
bringing you value again the the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles that I played with
at age seven if I hold on to them now
they're not gonna start late all of a
sudden Wow yeah I should start playing
with those again and when we we
Illustrated with such a
served terms and we can start to realize
that a lot of the physical possessions
that we have are sort of just grown up
versions of toys and and I'm not getting
value from this but maybe just maybe
someone else can so letting go of those
neckties sounds like you've got some
value from that yeah absolutely and
there's a there's a better way to
approach it for sure though definitely
so instead of giving them maybe ask them
if they need anything maybe try out the
donation or the yard the free yard sale
room and of course maybe try to sell a
few things if specially if you're in
debt done I think that will that will
that will help you on your journey of
letting go determining what things you
should sell what things you should
donate and of course is a leftover pile
there's gonna be trash there as well and
we need to be upfront and honest about
that if that you can recycle things
great if you can reuse things great but
it's already trash if it's just sitting
there in your house collecting dust Don
I'd love to send you a copy of our book
essential it's an essay collection with
a hundred and fifty essays about simple
living about intentional living and it's
sort of the best of the minimalist I
think there are two chapters in
particular that you'll find value and
there's a chapter on stuff actually
three chapters there's another chapter
in there four chapters because there's a
chapter on minimalism there's a chapter
on stuff there's a chapter on
relationships and there's a chapter on
contribution because that's one of the
things to think about here because the
stuffs collecting dust in your house
you're not really contributing beyond
yourself but if you let go of it you can
contribute beyond yourself in a
meaningful way so Sean if you reach out
to Don's center of the audio book of
essential essay the essay collection or
the book book or the e-book if she wants
those
you